cool right let's do it yeah every single
person in this room tonight has an
opportunity now that opportunity is to
build a personal brand now what is the
most important thing to me about
personal brand is the personal part you
have to be authentic and stay true to
yourself now no that's difficult when
you're worried about other people's
opinions but if you try and build a
personal brand around around things that
you don't actually believe in this is
simply not sustainable long term so if
you're a great recruiter and you try and
invest in your personal brand you will
be perceived as a great recruiter now if
you genuinely care about the canit's and
clients that you provide a service to
your can it's and clients will perceive
your personal brand that way now if
you're a [ __ ] recruiter and you're
thinking how can I gain from having a
personal brand and you start sharing
content around things you don't actually
believe in and aren't true
you are literally one comment away from
being completely exposed for what you
stand for so while I talk about now is
the most common objections I hear when I
speak to recruiters about investing in
their personal brand so the first one is
hisham I'm too busy I'm a recruiter
you're going to have jobs to work you're
gonna have candidates to find you're
gonna have business development calls to
make and you're gonna have a meeting to
attend trust me I get it
I've done it what do I have to say to
people that tell me they're too busy to
invest in their personal brand [ __ ]
bollocks that's what I have to say so
let me give you some food for thought
okay I think it's very conservative of
me to say that you all at least spend 30
minutes a day scrolling through your
LinkedIn newsfeed and if you like me you
spend longer than 30 minutes each day
going for your Linkedin newsfeed so what
could you actually do in 30 minutes to
invest in your personal brand you could
record 30 one-minute videos for LinkedIn
you could share to LinkedIn post
articles you could write six LinkedIn
posts you could comment on 10 of your
candidates and clients pose you could do
so much in 30 minutes
okay Hisham I'll make the time well
what's our ROI in having a personal
brand the way I like to look at this is
what could you potentially lose and what
could you potentially miss out miss out
on like building a recruitment desk
building a personal brand takes time and
consistency we all know how rare it is
to pick up the phone for the first time
to a client and pick up all their jobs
but if you consistently share content
you are literally one post away from
Katan connects with a candidate or
client you don't currently know how much
could that new relationship be worth to
you and your recruitment desk so how can
you actually start building a personal
brand the first thing you need to do is
[ __ ] star that is what you need to do
so this week say to yourself I'm going
to do one post for it on LinkedIn and
then build momentum from there where are
you going to share this content should I
be on a social channel should I be doing
videos should I be doing blogs should I
be on LinkedIn start with what you feel
most comfortable with and then build
from there
but give some real for where are my
where is my candidates and clients
attention I'd probably say LinkedIn is
the best place to start the majority of
recruiters now in terms of that what
should you be right and want you to be
sharing you speak to can its and clients
every single day share what you talked
about
don't let being creative hold you back
from sharing your thoughts documenting
over creating will allow you to stay
consistent okay
now you cannot share content with the
expectation of getting something in
return
because you're going to be disheartened
you're gonna be discouraged when you
share five posts and you get absolutely
fuchal for it which means you're going
to stop before you've even started okay
but what can give you a potential quick
win is collaborate some of others so
this week get on the phone so you can
action clients that absolutely love you
and sing your praises and get them to
share a post online instantly you're
going to be in front of a brand new
network that you've never been in front
of before okay what helped me stay
motivated were the small wins so if you
speak to a candidate or client for the
very first time and they say oh I've
actually seen your content online or I
recognize your name
your face take a mental note of that
that is the power of a personal brand
and that will make your job as a
recruiter a lot easier now before I
finish building the personal brand is
exactly the same as building a
recruitment desk it takes time
persistence and consistency okay
everything that I've spoken to you guys
about tonight is not to replace their
traditional methods of recruitment okay
it still works
but if you combine marketing with
everything that you're doing at the
moment as a recruiter I really believe
that you have the chance to become a the
recruiter of choice in your space so the
opportunity is there to be taken with
both hands and if you start tonight
you're probably gonna be ahead of 75% of
your competitors and we all love to [ __ ]
on our competitors so be you and you
have every chance of winning
[Applause]